[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here and as always if
you enjoy my content please hit the like
button it's the only way the youtube
algorithm really notices my videos
so i just watched the first two episodes
of the apple adaptation of isaac
asimov's foundation show and i've got a
few things to say about it now the
foundation book series is of course one
of the most influential book series of
all time it's influenced dune
star wars pretty much every science
fiction
series thing pretty much every science
fiction thing that involves any kind of
galactic empire now there are seven
books in asimov's foundation series
prelude to foundation forward the
foundation then there's foundation which
was the first book released the third
book chronologically foundation and
empire
and the second foundation foundation's
edge and foundation and earth the
foundation series tells the story of the
rise and fall of a galactic society
mainly the rise of one not really the
fall which i think seems to be the key
difference between
the series and the show which i'll get
into now now i just want to say that
visually this show really really
impressed me it looks really really good
the cgi is really good it's very very
high budget it was very very pleasing on
the eyes it was like easy to look at
nothing was like ugly because sometimes
like you see something that's like
overdone with cgi and it's kind of like
hard to look at like i find star trek
discovery for instance very difficult to
look at everything's just like too shiny
all the time which to me doesn't feel
very much like star trek at all but this
is just the right amount of cgi which is
a lot because it is you know sci-fi
about a galactic empire but it's done
really really well it's not like jarring
and it doesn't hurt my eyes i thought
the sets on the show were pretty
believable but some of them were pretty
generic and in fact i think that a big
problem with the show is that everything
seems a bit generic and derivative which
is weird to say because
asimov's books influence so much science
fiction but the show itself
has definitely been influenced by the
sci-fi material that has come out since
asimov's books for instance a lot of the
shots and a lot of the scenery kind of
look like star wars it looks really
similar to star wars there's a few star
wars things that happen there's a few
star wars things that happen over the
course of these few episodes like you
know like some death star action
basically um there's some there's a
sigil that looks pretty much like a star
wars imperial sigil thing and then
there's also some dune influence all
over this there's a character in this
that when you first meet her she's with
a little boy and it's very much
like a scene between
paul and jessica from dune it's like
she's definitely giving him like the
benny jesuit teachings there's something
that works similarly to the hollow deck
from star trek there's lots of things in
this that i've seen
in other places but that i haven't seen
in asimov's
books
so i will say
the first episode
seems to pretty much follow the course
of the book
um so it's it's you got gail dornick
going
down to trantor it gets on the space
elevator by the way the space elevator
looked super cool in this
meeting harry selden they get arrested
they
convince the emperor to let them build
on terminus it's pretty similar but with
a few liberties taken like there's this
terrorist attack that happens that's
not in the book and i'm pretty sure they
just put that in so they could have
their like big giant explosion moment it
looked cool but it wasn't from the book
it seems to be a part of this deeper
mystery involving the planets anachron
and thespis which are from later in the
book they have they have dealings with
terminus later in the book well anacrion
is involved later on thespis i'm pretty
sure they made up for the show so it
seems like this show is like
tying those two worlds into a mystery
involving this terrorist attack on
trantor and we really don't know what
the deal is with it yet so it seems like
what the show is doing is familiarizing
us with these worlds
before it actually gets to the point
where they become important later on in
the story
and speaking of later on in the story
there appeared to be time jumps
in
this show so it starts off
35 years in the future already on
terminus and then it jumps back
and then right at the end it jumps
forward again in the first episode and
you see that's 35 years in the future um
where they've already colonized terminus
and there's children there but then in
the next episode it jumped back to the
trantor days so this is when it started
taking the most liberties this is when
it really diverged from the book in the
second episode so the second episode is
all about the emperor
um who is sometimes referred to as the
empire so the empire is three guys it's
a boy
um a man and an old man so it's like
this guy whose emperor decided one day
that like he didn't want to die so he
just kept like they would keep cloning
him it's another thing in this show that
strikes me as like very like doonish you
know they even call it like a genetic
dynasty for some reason they never used
the phrase genetic dynasty in the dune
books but for some reason
that phrase sounds strikingly doomish to
me somehow but the second episode deals
with what he's doing in all of his three
incarnations we see more of the
character de mezriel who's got some
secrets you know and there are some
secrets hinted
in the second episode but if you haven't
read the books you don't know exactly
what secret but i know what the secret
is because i've read the books but you
see her interacting with mainly the
younger version of the empire the
emperor whatever he is you see her
interacting mainly with the younger one
um she's like kind of a teacher figure
she's hit she's she's the jessica to his
paul essentially and then we also see
how the older two are reacting to the
terrorist attack that happened on
trantor the
older
emperor seems to want peace he doesn't
want anybody to be executed he seems to
be like over he's past that stage in his
life but the younger one is all like
fire and blood he doesn't just want to
execute he wants to like ruin entire
planets there's like a huge
genocidal event in the second episode
where these two planets just get effed
up and it's not quite like in star wars
i mentioned the death star but it's not
quite like the death star where it just
like explodes it's more like
there's all these like little like nukes
it looked like that were firing on the
planet so it's like
a lot of death on each of these worlds
and he just did it to make a
statement i guess so these worlds will
definitely become significant later on
because they're significant in the book
and i feel like
they wouldn't have introduced them in
these first two episodes if they weren't
going to keep using them later on and
also another curious dune thing that's
randomly here is these
people have blue eyes that's like so
like it's not blue within blue but it's
like blue eyes it's like come on is it
also are they also gonna live on a
desert planet i don't know
the other part of episode two just
involved gail dornick harry selden and
some other new characters interacting
on the ship on their way to terminus and
like i said they've got the hollow deck
going they're like training we see that
gail dornick who's a female in the show
is like building a relationship and
that's going and now the important thing
here is in the book after gail dornick
and harry selden
decide they're going to go to terminus
and create the foundation
we don't see gail dornick again
like but it appears that in the show
they're finding a way to keep gail
dornick around as a character so in the
show harry selden is assassinated it
looks like and it's not clear exactly
why i'm not sure if it's like a snape
dumbledore thing where it's like harry
set this up so that he would be
assassinated because it seems like he's
the psycho history guy so he would have
known maybe that this was coming
but the result of it is gail dornick
it's like put in like this deep sleep
state and launched into space like and
we don't know where where she's gone so
i assume that gail dornick is gonna show
up
some point in the future
so they find they found a way to keep at
least gail dornick around
and it seems like at least some version
of the emperor is going to be around
consistently for a while
because there was talk in this episode
too about extending
the fall of the empire so it seems like
the show is taking liberties
with some of the characters in order to
keep them around for longer so you got
the emperor who constantly clones
himself so they'll be an emperor for a
while and they'll be able to use the
same actor over and over the same actors
over and over again for the emperor so
that's interesting i don't mind the
character changes very much because i
don't feel like as asimov particularly
gave that much care to his characters
the foundation series isn't really about
characters at all it's about the
formation of the galactic empire and the
continuation of the human species so i
will say the episodes kept me
entertained for the most part but there
were a few problems i thought that the
dialogue wasn't that great particularly
and most of the dialogue in these
episodes like the vast majority of it is
not in the books so it's like all new or
some of it it's like rework dialogue
from what's in the books but it's mostly
new dialogue
um
it's not the best
it's not awful it's kind of
mediocre to average but it's but it's
not making me cringe it's nowhere near
the level of like game of thrones season
six through eight so it's decent for a
television or maybe even above average
for television i would say i did find
the acting in the show to be a bit
wooden at times
i did find the acting in the show to be
like a bit wooden at times especially
with i'm sorry to say gail dornick
i i just wasn't really like
feeling like
her from like an emotional perspective
it's clear that they're trying to make
the character
it's clear that she's the central
character in all this it's we're seeing
this a lot largely through her lens
she's even narrating at certain points
and i felt like for a lot of it she
wasn't giving me exactly what i needed
in order to care and a lot of it could
come from the way the show plays out and
the way it's written for instance the
romance that forms the formation of the
romance between her and the guy
character that i can't remember the name
of that's not in the book
um it happens off screen like the first
episode they have no romantic connection
and then the next time we see them in
the second episode a bunch of time is
jumped in between episodes and they
suddenly have this romantic connection
and there's been no time on screen to
build it so you don't really feel
anything
for this couple and so by the end of the
episode when they're separated it's kind
of just like i don't really care that
much and i thought certain parts of the
emperor empire plot were pretty like i
said derivative
and kind of tired like the whole like
let me execute a bunch of people
and
it's so like want to be like game of
thrones and i'm just like i i don't care
like we've seen this a million times at
this point like like
mass execution like why does everything
have to have a mass execution in it
i don't get it i guess it would have
made more sense so i wouldn't have
minded it as much is
if i understood his reasoning for doing
it because this mass execution and then
also attacking these two worlds
is only going going to quicken the fall
of your empire i don't understand why
you're doing this it doesn't make any
sense um so yeah that part of it was
just like a little bit yeah i don't
really get this this just seems like
it's done for show this is done so they
can have this big moment with a bunch of
explosions and i kind of felt the same
way
about the fall of the space elevator
although it looked cool it was done just
so they could have this big moment like
oh this big thing falling down and also
like
i don't understand how
the space elevator wasn't more protected
it seems like you have something like a
space elevator it should be like more
able to detect bombs it was like some
weird thing where these people their
bodies were explosives somehow but i
just think
like in this age
so far into the future with something so
crucial as a space elevator like if this
thing like collapses it's going to kill
like 100 million people there would be
like more you know more defenses more
like ways to defend against this but i
guess there weren't all in all i think
the show's not perfect
but it's a decent start and though it's
definitely taking a bunch of liberties
with the material i think that it still
has not yet disrespected the source
material so i will keep watching and
it's entertaining enough i think the
show is doing a decent enough job of
like setting up certain mysteries and
setting up certain intrigues but i'm
really really hoping that they're not
going to turn the scale dornick plot
into some kind of like
messiah likes
mental psychics chosen one thing
because i was kind of getting that vibe
in the first episode a little bit that
they were going to do this gail adorning
chosen one thing and i'm just like
please don't do the guild dornan chosen
one thing like i don't want to see it
nobody needs that please don't do it but
other than that um i would say the show
is not
bad it's not half bad it's not
perfect like i said but i don't hate it
i would say i'm excited to watch the
next episode i know i'm excited to see
where it goes it looks like the next
episode they will be arriving on trantor
so the next episode's set on trantor i'm
curious to see when the next time jump
will happen
and if they're gonna stay in that period
or if it's gonna be a thing whereas like
sometimes we're like in the future and
sometimes from the past and sometimes
we're in a different time if it's gonna
keep jumping back and forth or not i
feel like if it did jump back and forth
over and over again that could get kind
of annoying so i'm hoping that like they
when they
finally jump they don't keep going
backwards all right guys so that's my
review of the first two episodes of the
apple tv foundation show like i said i'm
excited for the next episode and i'm
excited to see how they portray the rest
of it um
really really happy about the visuals in
this i think the visuals alone are
enough reason to watch it like the
visuals are great they really really did
a good job
with the look of this it looks just
about as good as anything else you
it looks just about as good as any like
sci-fi movie it's like really clear that
they spent a lot of money on the cgi
budget and the sets uh it looks really
really good so
just for that if you have a nice big tv
turn this on and
have yourself a drink and you know it's
fun one more thing my favorite
conversation in the show was when gail
dornick goes to the foundation
board members meeting or whatever it is
and
they're talking about what they're going
to preserve
in the encyclopedia galactica and we
have this interesting moment where the
character gail dornick she kind of
exposes the narrow-mindedness of some of
the board members when she talks about
what numeric system is going to be
preserved and how certain systems and
how certain planetary systems use
12-digit numeric systems instead of
10-digit numeric systems like we do and
she's talking about like they as the
foundation get to decide
what history lives on which that's such
a
important role so that was a cool
conversation a cool scene that gave me
hope that some of the ideas and
philosophies from this book would
uh remain in the show and be seen in
future episodes i'm super
ready for it peace out guys
[Music]
[Music]
you